hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we're going to be
talking about the patch version 1.08
that is going to be released tomorrow
for PC and then sadly next week on
console so sucks for us console players
but before we get into that I just want
to let everybody know the warden one
chocolate I covered in yesterday's video
has been patched as of Tuesday which was
yesterday 8 a.m. so if you did not want
to play the game because of that glitch
you can now come back on and have no
worries and then next I just want to
congratulate all my fellow Knights for
taking a w into in the first round of
season 2 only took us a season but we
finally got the W and hopefully we'll
get that season voice let's get started
with this patch so first off for some
characters this patch includes a nerf
and a couple of - Centurion Centurions
Eagle talons his Eagle towns by having
the hit recovery be longer when
canceling into revenge mode I don't
really play a lot of the DLC characters
so I hadn't really no idea you can
cancel into revenge mode but I guess
they made it a lot longer so that it
wasn't as you know spammable the next
thing is that the jab got nerfed by
making this dagger window be increased
when you're up against the wall the
reason is that for this the players
would always be stuck in a combo the
infinite chain combo whenever you were
jabbed into a wall so we're making the
stagger window increase a lot more so
that you can either block it parry it or
even get out of the way if you even have
the opportunity for that making
Centurion way less effective again when
you're up against the wall and lastly
his dodge role has been has gotten fixed
so that now he can't be God broken while
rolling next up the shinobi except
they're only a few bug fixes Shinobi's
roll also got the same fix of Centurion
making him guard making him not guard
broken wall dodging and then they also
fixed the bug were shinobi would get
stuck in objects when deflecting another
person so I'm glad they fixed that I
personally have not seen that with
shinobi but I feel like they'd be a
little bit of a joke that have came up
in a match moving on Kent says finally
in a patch for once but it's not really
that great they're only taking away the
unblockable icon from the combo and
putting it on the specific move itself I
guess some new players kind of got
confused on whether one tat one attack
or the whole combo was unblockable so
that's been fixed and they also added an
entry for superior block
dodj the next character and the very
last character for this update is going
to be peacekeeper peacekeeper the only
thing that got changed with her is that
Ubisoft updated her description on the
side of the moves list and now it says
that heavies can be canceled into a
guard break I find this a bit weird
because character every character except
conquer can do this because characters
only character they can't think unless
they're not talking about fainting and
what she can do is what's called a soft
Fink for anyone that doesn't know Kenta
can do soft faints when he does his
unblockable and he does his last hit in
the combo and it's unblockable you can
point your analog stick or whatever you
happen to use for your counselor PC into
a different direction and then click the
heavy button or a deal light button and
it will automatically switch guard
stances and do the attack instead of
cancelling it and then swinging that's
called a soft faint so they might be
giving her a soft faint I have no idea
but I mean I've never played peacekeeper
before so many of you have please be
sure to let me know this next section is
going to be a few couple bugs about
regarding the maps the first one they
fix the glitch where the players would
be climbing and have climbing animations
while not being near a ladder and then
the last thing they fixed was they fixed
a bug where a minor drop would cause the
players to fall maybe like a few inches
whether you tripped over a rock or
something and they also fix the multiple
visual glitches but they didn't state
what they were but it's still always
nice to have the next two things I kind
of find interesting was about the UI two
ornaments in the game that got changed
with their name the winged one outfit or
the winged one ornament for warden has
now gotten changed to daubeny shame so
ripped albany and then for chicagee his
ten armed monk was now changed to 12
armed monk I guess there was a post on
Reddit I believe seeing that it proved
that there was no 10 arms it was
actually 12 so they did change it to
that speaking of daubeny and a bunch of
other ornaments of the game there was a
post that's been surfacing on reddit for
a bit and also got what's called a UV
response whenever you're on reddit and
the icon do be response comes up it's
one of the moderators or one of the devs
talking about a reddit post that they
kind of answered in and gave their
opinion on but basically there was this
photo of a of the winged one ornament
with warden and then it changed to a
different color and it just didn't look
right it was the bronze ornament with
like a black shading so it didn't
fit the character at all and someone
said that they should have the option to
make the ornament match the color or the
material of your armor at the same time
so having a instead of having a bronze
ornament it would be black I personally
do like this idea because to be honest
most of the knight ornaments don't
really look that great and I feel like
they'd be way better with this option
for more of the D for honor fashion
reddit and then also Eric Pope did
respond to this thing that he sent it up
to Ubisoft see if they can have a look
of it and who knows maybe it could
actually be in the game eventually I
don't know what you guys would think I
put it up obviously in the video just so
you guys can get an understanding what
I'm talking about but tell me in the
comments below what you think if this is
worth it or not the last couple things
regarding bug fixes though was that they
change the players will all be awarded
for compliers will not be rewarded for
completing player versus AI matches
there was a bug that whenever you've
played player versus AI you were not
given your rewards at the end of the
game so now you're going to be given
that and then the Shinobi ornament POS
and the Centurion ornament sent to a
centaur I've now been gifted to all
players due to a bug in the unlock
condition so great we give free
ornaments now and then shinobi and
Centurion have their names changed from
Vanguard to assassin I don't remember
their names ever being Vanguard I've
been playing for honor for the past
couple days inflated today and I don't
remember their names being Vanguard I
could have sworn it was only and always
Sasson but I guess I guess a couple
people hasn't had their change but it's
a change to all take it and then lastly
probably the biggest part of this whole
thing is the quitter penalty not a
couple a couple videos ago I did make a
video explaining quitter penalty that it
was going to be worked on but it I never
did state what it was because that
Ubisoft didn't even know what they were
going to do yet well now we have our
answers so let me read this to you
players will receive a warning message
about the penalty before recording a
match if a player proceeds to quit via
the game menu or alt f4 they will
receive a 10-minute matchmaking penalty
this penalty is only applicable to all
group members if their leader leaves
there's a 30 second grace window at the
match start account for incomplete
groups and matchmaking issues this quick
penalty only applies to games played
their matchmaking meaning if you were to
lag out of the game you will not get
faulted for this and you will not get a
10-minute penalty so luckily they did
add this and it
makes the game a little bit easier and
hopefully makes people stop raging which
would hopefully reduce the connection a
lot of people have been staying saying
that the connection issue is a problem
mostly because of the people leaving and
they're getting pissed off
so then getting a greater than getting
like a suspension for like 10 minutes
would hopefully reduce some of the some
of them from joining matches will then
lessen the amount of problems on the
server and then hopefully making us not
crash every game of Dominion anyway guys
that is going to be the end of the video
for today I hope you all did enjoy this
please leave a like if you did enjoyed
this like it if you didn't subscribe if
you're new always putting up to 4 on our
content you can click the card or the
annotation on the top right to go see in
my previous video we did discuss and
talk about the warden one-shot code
which I know that it has been patched as
of Tuesday but if you didn't want to say
what it looked like at any point in time
just for some laps or whatnot go check
it out I'd be highly appreciated if you
have any ideas for videos like I said in
the past couple times but if you do have
any video ideas for me leave them in the
comments I can look at them and we can
maybe make a video out of it but like I
said thank you all for watching the
video today and I will see you all
tomorrow for the dead stream recap
tomorrow and peace out guys see you
later